Christian.
Hallelujah.
Heat
up here.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
Jesus.
Are you
Christian?
for me.
Hey
Hello, welcome everybody. So lovely to
see all of you here and online. Hello
friends out there in the ether. It's
nice to see you too. Um we are glad you
are here. Um whether it's your first
time or you've been here for a while,
we're glad you're here today. Um, so
couple of announcements before we get
started. All the announcements you'll be
able to find with the QR code. Anything
really that I talk about for the most
part will be on the QR QR code. So, uh,
feel free to give that a scan if you
want more information.
Um, Sunday Unbound for the next Sunday
Unbound, which will be on May 31st.
Write that down if you want to know. May
31st. Um, we are heading outside of
these
more than four walls. Um, but we are
currently to uh work within the
community. So, we are soliciting ideas
from you and you and you and you and you
and me and those folks out there. So, we
want your ideas. There is a link tree
form um that you can fill out, submit
your ideas. The team will then go over
that and we'll select something that
we're all going to go do together on May
31st. So, um whether it's helping out a
member of the church, a neighborhood in
your person in your neighborhood that
needs help, uh let us know. We want to
know about how we can help. Um second
announcement, Holy Week is right around
the corner. So, next Sunday, Holy Week
will kick off with Palm Sunday. Um so,
there'll be a special service. Make sure
to join us. And then Good Friday, we
will attend right here with Sax First
United. Um, and that will be at 700 p.m.
Yep. 7 p.m. on April 3rd. It is a
Canata, so it will be mostly music
centered on the cross. Um, and then
Easter, because we share the space, we
will be doing Easter on Saturday, April
4th. Easter service and meal. We'll be
catering food and doing an egg hunt. So,
uh, bring your kids or, I mean, bring
your own basket. I don't know if you
want to fight for candy. You might be
able to. I mean, that's up to you. No.
Oh, I'm sorry. I got killed. No. Oh,
sixth grade and under. Okay. So,
fortunately, I failed out of school, so
I'm still good. Um,
but because of that, there will be no
service on Sunday, April 5th. So,
Easter, April 4th here, meal, egg hunt
for kids in sixth grade and under, um,
on April 4th. And that, did I say a time
for that? I don't remember.
I don't know that I have a time. Okay.
Anyways, I'm not going to get distracted
by that. Um,
if you are anxious about being here
today, um, in this church setting, part
of disability community, feeling
fidgety, there is an accessibility
bucket over on that small cordenza over
there. Um, there are noise cancelling
headphones, fidgets, coloring sheets. We
just ask that you return them at the end
of service if you need them.
So, as we begin tonight, I invite you to
close your eyes and take a deep breath.
In and now out,
settling into the peace and stillness of
God.
These candles are a symbol of the
mystery of the loving presence of Christ
among us. A mystery we do not control or
contain, but rather one that meets us in
our unknowing and gently invites us
towards healing and wholeness.
Now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry,
and productivity. Now we enter the
kingdom of silence, stillness and
simplicity. Sacred space, a place for
prayer, worship and adoration. A place
to behold Christ, revelation of God,
heartbeat of creation. Allow the
unforced rhythms of grace to find you,
to mend your heart. May we all come
home.
>> Thank you, Jared. If you guys want to
stand with us, we're going to get
started with our music.
And I just want to know who could feel
anxious when someone's standing up in
front of us in a Robin Hood shirt. I was
sitting here like, "Oh my goodness,
Robin Hood and Little John walking
through the forest." Now I wish we were
singing that song.
I love it.
All right, we're going to start out with
Never See the End tonight. And I love
that this song reminds us just that the
goodness of God is never ending. Um it
doesn't fall short. It doesn't um it
doesn't stop whenever our goodness
stops. Um so let's sink oursel into that
truth tonight as we worship together.
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
You will not find us.
The deepest of depths,
the highest of heights.
Your love it chases
us.
And no matter where we've been, no
matter what we've done,
we can't escape
your love.
Oh,
we will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
Oh,
though we pass through the fire or we
pass through the flood,
you will be with us.
Though we walk through the valley of the
darkest of nights,
your love will be
our light.
And when we are in plenty and we are in
want,
you will always be
enough.
Oh,
cuz we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
Oh.
And in our darkest hour and on our
hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave
and you will not forsake
the promises that you have made.
And in our darkest hours and on a
hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you will never leave
and you will not forsake
the promise that you have made.
And we will say
that we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
All
right. Well, you guys can follow Shiloh
right out to our kids ministry doors and
our teachers will meet you guys over
there. Thank you, kids ministry team for
loving on those kiddos and teaching them
about the love of Christ. So grateful
for y'all.
We go.
All right, we're going to transition
into the prayers of the people. Um, I
think you guys have been with us before,
but follow along on the screens and the
parts in red. We will read out loud
together. Um, we'll also leave a a
moment in the middle for you to share
anything that's on your heart that
you're carrying into this space. And we
just want to hold that up before God
together as a community, believing that
he is with us in our joy and in our
pain.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick.
For the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering, we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute. for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
You call me strong and courageous
when I don't feel like I again.
You could have turned me away, but you
chose me instead.
You say that I'm going to make it
when I don't feel like I can.
You see the battle I'm facing and you're
stepping in.
You're in it with me,
working through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
>> You're in it with me,
>> working through me,
>> fighting for me. God is not against me.
I have a new revelation.
A savior who calls me his friend.
I used to fight on my own over
again.
I have a power that's gater
than all of the enies lies.
I know the truth of the goel, but you're
on my side. You're on my side.
In here with me,
working through me.
fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
Fighting for me. God is not against me.
You're in it with me.
You're working through me.
Fighting for me. God is not against me.
In it with me.
working through me,
fighting for me. God is not against me.
>> This is not my fight. You are my
defense.
You hold my life. This is my confidence.
You are by my side.
You call me friend. You hold my life.
This is my confidence. This is not my
fight. You are my defense.
You hold my life. This is my confidence.
You are by my side. You call me friend.
Feel it with me.
Work it through me.
Fighting for me. God is not against me.
Feel it with me.
Work it through me.
Fighting for me. God is not against me.
God is not against me.
I Sing the thou my vision. Be thou my
vision.
Oh Lord of my heart.
Save me all else to me. Save that thou.
Thou my best thought
by day or by night.
making or steeping
my presence, my life.
Be thou my wisdom and my true way.
I ever with thee and thou with me, Lord.
Thou my great father
and I thy true son.
Thou in me dwelling
and I with thee.
High King of heaven,
my victory
won.
May I reach heaven's joy so bright,
heaven sun,
heart of my own heart would ever be
full,
still be my vision,
oh ruler
of all.
still be my vision.
Oh ruler
of
God, would we set our eyes and our
hearts on you
when the world around us is sinking
sand?
When there seems to be no firm
foundation, God, would you be our rock,
when everything else is confusion?
Would you be our clarity?
when we feel surrounded by darkness.
God, would your light pierce through?
And would we anchor into you, into your
love,
your goodness that does not end?
And would it carry us through?
Would it unite us? Would it bring us
together?
Yeah, God be our hold. Be our center.
It's in your name I pray all these
things.
Amen.
All right. Could you guys turn to the
person on your right or left and say,
"The peace of Christ be with you." And
then Brett will get us started on our
message.
Grace and peace.
It is uh it's good to be with you all
and uh yeah, good to to welcome you into
this space. My name is Brett and I'm the
pastor here and uh yeah, it's a joy joy
to be with you in this Linton season and
as always that also includes those join
us online. y'all are not forgotten. And
uh and anyone else here tonight who is
new, thank you um for having the courage
to come through those double doors. I
know it can it can be a lot coming into
a new space. And I mean any kind of
community, but specifically church, you
know, people um well, I'll just say it's
it's rare someone comes through those
doors without quite a bit of like
baggage and often even like downright
just pain and hurt from church. So, um,
we're really really, uh, grateful that
you're that you're here with us. And,
uh, this is our fifth Sunday in Lent,
uh, which is this kind of time of just
prayer and fasting as we, uh, approach,
you know, Good Friday. That's the day of
the cross, and then, uh, into Easter.
And, uh, like Jared was mentioning, a
week from today, uh, is the beginning of
Holy Week. that kicks off with Palm
Sunday, which if you've been here for
Palm Sunday, you know it's a special day
in uh at the table. And so we encourage
you, you don't want to miss it. If you
know, you know. And uh yeah, it'll be a
really fun time next week. And then
that'll kind of take us into into Holy
Week and and all of that. Um so yeah,
it's a really it's a a beautiful time of
year in uh in the kind of the Christian
community. Um, so the uh title of my
message this this week is uh from
despair to hope. From despair to hope.
And um this you know kind of we're we're
in kind of a series right now, but it's
really just the season of Lent. So we're
following like the the church calendar
and um certain prescribed readings. So,
uh, you'll notice as we've been going,
you know, it's often, um, the passages
that, uh, churches tend to kind of
preach on, it's it's ones that are, you
know, it's like scenes of like the
desert or the valley. you know, these
are all kind of metaphors for the the
this time of lint, which is um well, I
mean, it's in in ways it's something
quite counterultural because it's trying
to intentionally open up some space for
I don't know, you might call it like the
sort of the the challenging emotions in
life, you know, the space like some
space for a little grief or um a little
sense of loss or pain. And you know,
it's it's amazing how we often go
through life kind of like avoiding that,
you know? And I mean, just living in
America, it's like this carnival of just
distraction, you know what I mean? Like
it just you can just go through your
days constantly kind of like stimulated
and like, you know, notifications just
ding ding ding just distracted,
distracted, like I don't want to deal
with that. And the culture is almost
designed to be like perfect, we don't
want you to deal with that either, you
know, just just be distracted. Come over
here. So this season is it's quite
counterculture. It's really
intentionally like no no no no no
there's well because again why because
we're coming into the cross right and
what's the cross but kind of this image
of suffering and it's saying like this
is a part of life this is like a part of
the human experience and we you know we
need space for that. So, um, yeah. So,
that's, you'll notice in our in our
passage today, um, Ezekiel 37 1-10, it's
this vision of like bones and in a a
valley of dry bones. So, you can already
see right the the kind of Linton like
metaphor there. Um, now, uh, before I
jump into the passage, I want to say a
little bit more from about the title,
despair to hope. Uh, you know, I think
it's probably no, well, it's not any
surprise to say that. Uh I say our
country right now like if I'm picking up
on the vibes not just of you all but
even just what I'm hearing on the
socials and stuff like it's just not a
time of broad optimism in the country.
We'll put it mildly like there's just a
lot of like it's just like and honestly
it's been like that for years. There's
this kind of collective like you know
it's it's not a time where people are
like super optimistic about the future
and you know oh my gosh I'm just filled
with hope like uh that's not generally
the the vibe. you know there's there's a
a kind of um I don't know almost a quiet
despair you know where kind of our faith
I think in like institutions certainly
is low um whether that's the church like
you know religion business uh politics
just in every way it's just just kind of
like a
and uh so I think that you know it that
bodess well for the Linton season you
know to kind of like sit with that feel
that get into it a little bit so
certainly this passage I think um speaks
right to that. So this is uh the prophet
Ezekiel in chapter 37, he's given this
vision of a valley of bones. So verse
one, it says this, "The hand of the Lord
was on me and he brought me out by the
spirit of the Lord and he set me in the
middle of a valley. It was full of
bones.
He led me back and forth among them."
We'll come back to that. And I saw a
great many bones on the floor of the
valley. Bones that were very dry.
All right. So, how do we, you know, what
do we take from this? And how do we move
from despair to hope? I I'll say this.
Step one, I'm going to say that we've
got to first kind of allow yourself to
be led into the valley. That's kind of
what I was hinting at with this whole
Linton season. And we often resist this,
but it's like no, no, no, no. Don't like
Ezekiel like let yourself go into that
place of, you know, that place of kind
of a sense of loss, um, despair,
struggle, pain. Uh, allow yourself to
kind of be there and go into that. Um,
I've been in this, I mean, it's amazing
how this lined up with the the season of
Lent, but I have had, uh, backto-back
funerals on Monday. In fact, some of you
are wondering like, I haven't had an
e-letter in a while. That's usually
because I write it on Monday, even
though it goes out Thursday, but I write
it Monday, but the last two weeks I've
just had funeral. And the one I had this
past Monday was um it was super sad, but
it, you know, not in quite the same way
because it was a 93 year old man and you
lived this like full life and there's
always like a a deep grief with death,
but there's something, you know, about
when someone kind of lives to their
fullness of their years and then passes
on. And you know, um the the one before
that though, uh it was uh different. Um
was a young man, uh 14 if I recall. Um
and his name was Idan and he uh played
on my son Dax's soccer team and I had
the privilege of coaching him for like I
mean years basically. It was like kind
of interesting this league and we played
in Garland so they kept the team you
know together. So, it was like season
after season after season, we just
played. And uh I'll say Iden Iden, he
was he was freaking amazing. I mean, he
was far and away the best player on like
our team. I don't think my son Dax, if
he were here, he's actually out of game,
but if he he wouldn't be offended by
that. He knows Iden was unbelievable. In
fact, Iden was probably the best player
in the league. He made me look like an
actually good soccer coach. The truth
is, I had no idea. I was, you know, I
played baseball and swim team, you know,
that was what I did. And so he I mean,
he was a girl. I remember this one um he
was so competitive. And this one moment
or this one memory kind of sticks out
where we were down by two. We're playing
like like second or third best team in
the league. It was a tight game. And we
were down by two. There's like two
minutes left. And uh in his Bosnian
accent, he runs over to the sideline to
me. He says, "Don't worry, coach. Don't
worry. We going to score. I got you. I
got you. And he steals the ball. He
dribbles through everyone. He scores. He
runs. He grabs the ball. Slams it in the
middle of the field. They get it. He
steals it from them. He dribbles through
everyone. He scores. Like a minute
later, he gets this set piece. He has
like 40 yards to the goal. This is when
he's like, I don't know, 10.
And he shoots like it has bend on. He's
like bends like scores. He runs back
over to me. He's like, "I told you,
coach. I told you." I mean, he he was a
competitive maniac. It was awesome. Just
a what a great kid. Um, and about two
years, two, three years ago, um, he got
diagnosed with I don't know the exact
disease, but it's basically something
that if left untreated, it would become
like childhood leukemia. So he was like
in and out of the hospital, you know,
did not play soccer um and getting all
the treatments and eventually got like a
bone marrow transplant from his mom and
um started like improved actually last
season was able to come back play uh
soccer again. Um he was you could tell
he was still like quite weak and you
know recovering but better and uh and
then he got some they took him off
certain medication and he got like some
kind of fungal infection something and
the doctor said like there's like no
coming back from this and and sure
enough he ended up just like two weeks
after that um ended up passing away and
um
it was like well there's just something
about like the death of a child you You
know what I mean? Like it it just is it
hits you. Like he passed away on a
Friday. That next Saturday, the next
day, Maggie and I went to their home
because we're quite close, you know,
been we've known these folks for years.
Went to his parents' home. And you know
what it's like to like enter into a
house of grief,
you know, like like you can even if no
one says anything, it's almost like you
can fe you can just feel the emotions in
that space, you know? And there was just
something meaningful, difficult,
powerful, you know, about like just kind
of being in that valley of bones with
them.
The he was buried on the next Monday um
Muslim funeral which I'd never been to.
It was fascinating. It was different. Um
no like service in a building. It was
all graveside. and the his father, his
uncle, literally they have him shrouded
and they pick him up and they like lay
him into the tomb. Like they're standing
in the grave and they like lay him in
and then um they had uh the men all
gather and they um get three handfuls of
dirt and you you know you place it kind
of on him like literally you participate
you know in the burial. It was so
powerful as I I sat there not only for
myself like participate. I mean what a
moment you know to like kind of like say
goodbye, you know what I mean? Like and
it's like bodily like you're this is no
abstract, you know, like you were like
there. Um but it was so powerful to
watch not only my son but like I mean so
many of his teammates through the years
like showed up all wearing their
jerseys, you know, and to see them like
pick up that dirt like place it on, you
know. Um
what what I appreciate about that moment
was like to see them like those young
men who could have so easily like it's
kind of bo you know like they had school
and you know but like for them to show
up and say like no no no this matters
this is important. I'm not going to look
away. I'm not going to avoid it but I'm
going to like be there. You know what I
mean? in that valley, in that
desolation, in that just pain and
struggle.
Just like Ezekiel, I'm going into the
valley of the bones. I'm really struck
in our text that Ezekiel says, he says,
"He being God, like the spirit of God,
he led me back and forth." That
interesting phrase,
back and forth. Right? In other words,
this is no like, you know, from a
distance, the Lord kind of showed me and
I saw a way out there. There's like this
valley and I was like, "Oh, thank God. I
don't have to go there." You like, "No,
no, no. There's this not only is he like
right in it, but the spirit, you know,
leads him back and forth among the
bones."
I think there's there's almost like
God's saying to him like Ezekiel and
kind of to us, you know, don't look
away.
Don't look away. No, no, no. Be here.
Enter into it. See it. You know, most of
us or many of us when confronted with
times of grief and death and loss, oh,
isn't there something in us that's just
like
escape, you know, just run or get get
away. Um, but no, no, God says, I'm
going to I'm going to lead you back and
forth.
uh which can sound like cruelty,
you know, uh but it's not. If you know
anything about grief, you know, like no,
no, no, it it must be faced,
you know, it must be faced. And there
there's something about a opening up a
season, a space, a time for that, to
grieve, to feel. And we do that in so
many ways, you know. Um thank God for
the actually number many therapists here
at the at the table. And um that's one
way we do we go go to therapy to have
find a safe space you know to uh talk to
process um it can happen through um even
just processing though with friends uh a
number of you go to like our midweek
kind of like small groups and share your
highs and lows and that becomes like
this little opening you know to like be
real and to share not only the good
parts but like the valley of bones kind
of stuff you know to to open up about
those losses um journaling, prayer,
silence, right? These are all ways that
we kind of allow ourselves to be led
into the valley. So that's step one. We
got to we can't resist it. You know what
I mean? Or else the process from
despared hope it doesn't begin you know.
So first we got to enter into the
valley. Uh step two we need to practice
a posture of and this may surprise you.
Um but we got to practice a posture of I
don't know.
Practice a posture of I don't know.
There's so there's Ezekiel right being
led back and forth among these bones.
And then verse three, he asked me, son
of man,
can these bones live?
And I said, sovereign Lord, you alone
know? You know, I'm I'm struck that
like, well, I'm struck by his answer
here. I don't know. I think, well, I'm
like, you know, even from my youngest
years, I was always like trying to be
that good Christian kid. I think maybe I
would have known the right answer, you
know. Yes, of course, Lord. Yes, of
course these bones can live. You know,
um I'm struck that Ezekiel doesn't say
that, you know, what does he say? It's a
kind of very dead honest like
not sure,
you know, like like that's the kind of
implied, you know what I mean? He
doesn't say that, but it's like you
alone know.
Have you ever been there where it's just
like I don't know. It's just in God's
it's just in God's hands. God, you alone
know. I am I'm just not sure if I'm if
I'm being dead honest. I just can't give
a kind of hallelujah. Amen. You can do
anything, Lord. You know, like it's just
a a kind of
you alone know. But I see him kind of
finding a way between is like these two
extremes. Either a kind of I don't know
almost a forced optimism which you know
sometimes I do think we have a gift of
faith and we can believe and that's
beautiful. If you're in that place and
it's just like hallelujah, may I trust
you, God? And it's going to be great,
you know, that's wonderful. But
sometimes in Christian circles, it
becomes a kind of I don't know, it's
almost the culture where it's like, you
know, the right answer. Can these bones
live? You know the right answer, you
know, and it's this that kind of force.
Yes, Lord. Even if you don't feel it,
you know. Um or we kind of have the
other side, you know, which is this kind
of a a deep pessimism, you know, of just
like no, no, they cannot no. I mean,
look at these bones. I mean, he even
describes them like in a valley and
they're dry. They're very dry, you know.
It's just no, they can't live. Everyone
knows this, you know, and how we often
feel in the valley of bones, just likem
this is just dead and it just sucks.
It's just the worst. It's just the worst
and nothing's going to be better, you
know. There's we we kind of and that's
what I see Ezekiel. It's this middle
way. It's sort of a it's not a no and
it's not a yes. It's a kind of you know
you alone know. In other words, God,
this is kind of beyond me, but I I trust
you. I trust I trust somehow
you can your your kingdom come. Your
will can be done. You know, yeah,
there's a kind of openness um there, a
kind of dead level honest.
I don't know, but I trust that you, God,
you know. Have you been there? Have you
walked through that valley of dry, dead
bones.
The dry bones of infidelity, divorce,
the dry bones of addiction,
the dry bones of sexual abuse, the dry
bones of crushing debt, the bones of
trauma,
disillusionment.
Have you been there? Maybe you feel a
bit like Ezekiel longer than you'd like
being led back and forth
among the bones. You're like, when when
does this end? You know, when do we get
off this ride? You know, just being led
back and forth among the bones, dwelling
in a land.
And the Lord asks you, "Can these bones
live again?"
And you say, "I don't know.
You alone know.
That brings us to the the kind of
turning point in the story. We'll call
this step three.
Speaking life
even in the midst of death.
It's interesting here. God uh God
doesn't respond to Ezekiel's kind of
tentative, you alone know Lord. You
know, he doesn't he doesn't like
chastise him, you know. He doesn't say,
"Oh, ye of little faith, Ezekiel."
Uh, and he also doesn't like spring into
action and say, "Well, just look what I
can do." You know, a miracle. And you
know what? It's interesting his
response. Verse four, then the Lord said
to me,
"Prophesy
to these bones."
You know what's what strikes me there is
this kind of it's like almost this
participatory thing. You know what I
mean? is like, "Speak up, Ezekiel." You
know, like, "Go ahead, say it." Like,
"Say what? What do you mean?" Like, I'm
just imagine you're Ezekiel like, "You
want me to do what?" You know, prophesy
to the bones. Like, I mean, I'm just
wondering like I mean, it's easy when we
read these stories to kind of imagine,
well, Ezekiel, he's such a man of faith
and you know, he's just like, "Oh,
confident." Uh, but the context of the
story is he's not confident, you know?
He's like, "You alone know, you know."
So, imagine you're in that valley and
it's just desolation. It's like speak
life. speak life to the you know just
by the way the word prophecy here or
prophesy I don't I don't think he just
means like predict the future I don't
think he's saying predict the future
Ezekiel I think to to prophesy means
something like to you know to speak the
divinely inspired word uh in other words
the spirit-ledd word the word that
envisions you know life and not death
and that's what Ezekiel does is one of
the more famous passages in scripture
because of the metaphor in the image,
right? He's there surrounded by just
death and loss. And then verse seven,
so I prophesied as I was commanded and
as I was prophesying, there was a noise,
a rattling sound, and the bones came
together bone to bone. I looked and
tendons and flesh appeared on them and
skin covered them,
but there was no breath in them.
And then he said to me, "Prophesy to the
breath. Prophesy, son of man, and say to
it, this is what the sovereign Lord
says.
Come breath. Come from the four winds
and breathe into these slain that they
may live." So I prophesied as he
commanded me and breath entered them and
they came to life and they stood up on
their feet a vast army.
Now I I think this passage and this this
can be interpreted in many different
ways. It it certainly lends itself to a
kind of um I don't know what to call
almost like a a TV preacher kind of name
it and claim it theology. you know this
this kind of uh you know speak to the
bones in your life. You know what I
MEAN? LIKE NAME that miracle you want
you know name that fancy car that in
Jesus name and you know claim it and see
it and speak it into existence or you
know something uh something along these
lines. Um I think notice though the
context here it's not those kinds of
it's not like wealth and luxury and you
know it's not that's just not the the
imagery. I mean as we've been talking
about the image here it is dry bones you
know it's death it's desolation
so given that context I don't think the
you know our main takeaway here should
be you know something like claim that
promotion in Jesus name you know um I
think the takeaway is something more
like my life my culture it may feel like
a valley of dry dead bones
but God invites me to prophesy in other
words to express the possibility of a
lifegiving future.
So, I've been thinking, you know, what
is this like kind of what could this
look like in our life? You know, of
course, they looked like many, many
different ways. Um, I I came across the
one example. I actually heard from
people in our community recently. Uh,
and interesting, it was a different
religious tradition, but it was a a
group of 19 Terravada Buddhist monks who
just last month completed a 108day,
2,300
mile walk for peace. Do y'all see these
some like this movement online? I mean,
it was um absolutely incredible. Um, so
they they they're like locally. So they
started from their home temple in Fort
Worth and they walked to Washington DC.
Uh, kind of going like up through the
south like through like Mississippi and
Georgia and kind of up and uh walked to
Washington DC and then back again. And
they they said they wanted this to be a
spiritual offering.
And uh millions ended up following them
online. Thousands turned out in various
towns as they made their journey. When
asked what their mission was, uh they
said they just observed so much
suffering in the United States
that their their hope well basically
they hoped to be a kind of um an example
of peace
and mindfulness and prayer. They said
basically the hope was that in seeing
them or hearing about their journey and
mission that the inner peace they
possess would spread uh from them to
others
and then through others throughout the
world. And as I I went online to like to
look at this, it was interesting. I
could find a photo journal that people
had kept of their trip. And like some of
the images from this were absolutely um
remarkable. I think we have Yeah. of the
woman of the woman uh praying here and
crying like I'm I'm particularly
interested in this because I wonder like
what's happening like for her like what
is she receiving there? I think probably
in my um more kind of evangelical days
would have been quite concerned about
this image like oh my gosh she's like
praying to them or something you know um
I don't think that's what's happening. I
think um I think she's receiving the
message, you know. I mean, I think she's
rece I mean, in essence, uh,
we she we live in this kind of valley of
bones, and I think we're just desperate
for, um, examples
of like hope and peace and, you know,
like moves of the spirit, you know, like
people I just think are incredibly um,
just, you know, hungry, like hungry to
receive, like desperate
for someone who who themselves is not
completely
overwhelmed and undone
by the desolation and the loss in the
valley of bones. I think that's the the
beautiful thing those monks are um kind
of embodying and expressing. And I don't
know everyone's theology the way I think
of other religious traditions. I don't
think of them as sort of like it's like
there's Christianity, it's the right
one, and everyone else, those are all
just religions of the demons, you know,
that's not how I think of it. Um I I
think of like the spirit of God can be
present honestly to all people, right?
And so I think anytime someone takes a
walk for peace,
I don't think that's like, well, that's
of the devil, you know? I think no, no,
that's the that's the spirit of the
Lord. So I think that's the that's kind
of the movement, right? So it becomes
this kind of offering where they're
taking this walk through like literally
through America through the valley of
dry bones. And what do they do? They're
they're doing their best to breathe out
peacefully to to spread peace. Breathing
peace. Breathing just like Ezekiel,
right? Breathing life into dead places.
And I think just like those monks uh we
too in our own ways you know we're
invited to join in like Ezekiel we're
invited to participate
prophesy
to those bones.
So how can this look in our life? Well
here's I'll just give this like a little
application for the week. Uh I want to
encourage you to like look for the small
moments when through word or deed you
too can speak life to someone. You can
in essence in that moment kind of um
become a conduit for the spirit of
Christ to others. The spirit of well the
fruit of the spirit right of love and
joy and peace and patience and kindness
and goodness and gentleness and
faithfulness and self-control, right?
It's become a kind of a mouthpiece for
that. Um, it could be offering a small
word of encouragement. It could be just
practicing the presence of God,
remaining mindful and aware throughout
the day. That's kind of what those monks
practice. They would call it mindfulness
awareness. We would call it practicing
the presence of God. Um, it could be
just taking a few deep breaths uh before
responding in anger.
And in the end, you know, we may not be
able to do some sort of 2,000mi walk for
peace, you know, but we can still be an
Ezekielike people,
people rooted in the fruit of the
spirit, and the hope of Jesus Christ. In
the name of the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night before his death, Jesus
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it and eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you."
And he held up a cup of wine. He said,
"Take this drink. This is my blood. It's
shed for you. Whenever you eat this
bread, whenever you drink this cup,
remember me."
And so as we come forward to participate
tonight, we we literally we we kind of
join in with Christ. We we commune.
That's why we call it commune. We
commune um with Christ in his spirit. Uh
and those images right of of the bread
and the cup. It's an image of suffering.
So I encourage you tonight just as you
come forward bring whatever is on your
heart you know whatever that thing was
that you were thinking about as I was
speaking uh bring that forward and uh
and connect with Jesus in that in that
situation that um that thing in your
life. So the way we'll go about this is
we'll just go rowby row starting here at
the front and uh we'll form a line here
in the middle so when one row is kind of
done the next one can um jump up. We
practice an open table. So, if you're
here tonight and you would like to
participate in communion, you're free to
do that regardless of your exact like,
you know, theology or or beliefs or
something. If something in you wants to
connect with Jesus, then uh you're
you're free to to come forward and
participate in this time. Just know the
red is wine, the white is grape juice.
And uh finally, you can uh just partake
whenever you'd like. Some folks take
right away. Um others like to come
forward and kneel here. Um but no one
will lead you through the exact moment
of partaking. So this is the table not
of the church but of the Lord and it's
made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more. So
come you who have much faith and you who
have little. You who have been here
often and you who have not been here
long. You who have tried to follow and
you you feel like you failed. Come. Come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you. And it's his will that
those who want to meet him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
As we close out tonight, We're going to
sing a song called Beautiful Things. Um,
many of you have probably heard it a
number of times. It's kind of one of
those hallmark songs for me personally,
just because it's um a song that I felt
like uh I really needed at a specific
moment of grief when I was kind of in
the middle of my own valley of bones.
And uh the the words of this song have
always rung so true to me because it's
teaching me um to hope, teaching me to
trust
um when when I don't really want to
sometimes when it feels very hopeless.
Um, so tonight if you want to just sit
and I would love for you guys to sing
along with us, but if you want to just
stay in this posture of kind of
introspection
and um if you find these words to be
hopeful, if you find them to be
something that you can grab onto and and
maybe even specifically picture yourself
in your own valley um in your own
struggles and maybe hold open your hands
if you would like to and um and just
receive this um this message of hope.
This message of trust that we have in
Jesus,
all
this pain.
I wonder if I'll ever find my way.
I wonder if my life could really change
at all.
All
this earth.
Could all that is lost ever be found?
Could a garden come up from this ground
at all?
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of the
dust.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of us.
All
around
hope is springing up from this old
ground.
Out of chaos, life is being found
in you.
>> You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of the
dust.
>> You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of us.
>> Oh, you make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of the
dust.
You make beautiful things. You make
beautiful things out of us.
Oh.
You make me new. You are making
me new.
You make me
You are
do.
>> Oh, you make beautiful things. You make
beautiful things out of the dust.
You make beautiful things. You make
beautiful things out of us.
Oh,
Thank you so much for joining us
tonight. Um, if you are interested in
joining a small group, attending a table
event, or if you're new and would be
willing to fill out a visitor's card,
um, you can do so with the QR code, or,
uh, you can find those things at the,
uh, credenza over to my left on your way
out. Um, we would love to have a record
of your visit. So, um,
please reach out. We'd love to hear from
you in any of those facets. Um, I'm
going to ask Brett to come back up for a
minute and talk some more because he has
something he needs to talk about. and
then I'll be back.
>> Um, yeah, I won't take long on this, but
I wanted to name that uh we're kind of
looking at, you know, ahead kind of
financially for 2026 and um kind of
hoping to uh be able to do, kind of more
like ministry and um really helping
people. And uh 2025 was our first year
to ever kind of be just a little bit in
the red. So, we're really hoping to kind
of turn that around as we, you know,
move forward. So, if you call the table
home, again, if you're like visiting
this, you can ignore this, but if you
call the table home, this is like your
community. Um, then I want to invite you
to just consider pray about um giving
financially uh so that we can kind of um
well, basically it's just a way of
partnering, you know, like if you like
believe in this community and think
like, yeah, we need more of this in the
world. Well, um that's a you know, very
practical, tangible way um that you can
help make it happen. And it's, you know,
it's everything from our ability to rent
this space to the snacks the kids are
eating right now to I mean, just all
sorts of like a thousand practical
little um little things. And uh so yeah,
anyway, I just want to kind of put that
out there and uh invite you to uh
consider what you might be able to to
give as we kind of, you know, come into
this year. Thanks.
Thank you, Brett. All right, let me send
you into this week with a blessing. Um,
you can hold your hands out in a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day and it is
true on your worst day.
So as you go into the week ahead with
the yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between, go filled
with the assurance that you are loved.
You are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are. And go filled with God's
Holy Spirit and the desire to extend
these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with. Be blessed and we'll
see you back here next week.
You make me new. You are making
me new.
>> You make me new. You are making
>> You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
Oh, you make beautiful things. You make
beautiful things out of the dust.
You make beautiful things. You make
beautiful things out of us.
Oh.
Oh. Oh.